first of all yes bring me the fashion
who is this who made this what are you
wearing how do you feel in it
tonight i have on a ninja mckenzie look
and um i feel like royalty
i feel like a past that has never
happened
so okay so yes you look amazing but this
is a little different for you this year
because
here we are solo you what does it feel
like to be at the grammys
like without the band mates i mean i'm
honored i'm honored especially being in
a category
um full of women yeah it's exciting
um it is different this year yeah but
nonetheless
it means a lot it means a lot that i
took a chance to do something on my own
despite the consequences and here i am
does it
make the grammys feel different when you
already have the beautiful grammys on
your shelf
at home like is there less pressure
going into the nominations this year
um maybe but see they're not in my house
i gave them to my parents
you did so i knew some more to put in my
house all four
yeah they're all just split up they are
just you gave them to ever so you need
some for you now
yeah i just got i just bought a house
has a mantle in it so i'm gonna go ahead
and try to get myself tonight i think we
should get five
try to get five i'll go for five okay go
for five um
i wanna ask you about this performance
um we're hearing that it's it's quite
emotional
can you speak to that you know um i
think most of what i do is pretty
emotional
i think that is how i connect to other
people
through my performances and it's genuine
and to be honest i'm just going to do
what i do
and the collaboration with chris martin
can you talk about that
is it a surprise it's gonna be a
surprise we'll see who shows up
okay okay but now i mean now that you
have given the grammys to your parents
you have a lot of famous friends so if
you needed to text someone you could be
like
like could you come over to the grammys
with me oh probably i'd probably text um
michelle or barack obama okay you have
their phone number
oh yeah where's my phone okay i don't
have any pockets
okay you didn't bring any pockets
next time next time